所这个事情啊，
一个月充1万块钱打游戏这个事情啊，
他就是一个人的底色，
他就是火坑，
他说那话让我听来的话，
我甚至觉得有点可笑，
什么，
因为你跟你前面那个老公生的孩子，
你俩关系没有断，
所以我就要乱花钱，
你这玩意说出来的话，
你不觉得她自己有毛病吗？
那我现在是怀孕两个多月，
我这边是二婚，
结婚三年了，
因为工作跟我老公异地，
今年算是七月份辞职，
然后来这边备孕，
结果就有孩子了，
之前因为一直异地，
虽然结婚三年，
但是加上一起的时间在一块儿不到半年的样子，
在这两个月里面，
我因为一职来到我老公出差的地方了，
就是发现他我一玩游戏，
我就随便查了几个平台，
发现他基本上一个月就花1万多，
我一开始没发现打牌就只有打游戏这件事儿的时候，
我就很生气也很难过。
我问他原因，
他跟我说因为我是二婚嘛，
头婚的时候是有个儿子跟着他爸爸的，
我们两个结婚3年又一直没孩子，
他说他之前之所以挥霍钱，
是因为自己又没孩子，
然后又感觉我跟我儿子没有锻炼，
他就觉得害怕，
他说他都挣了钱没有意义，
他就花掉了。
说实话，
我觉得他有点甩锅，
但是后来人家都劝我说人家你老公说的也是心里话。
也能理解，
我也就忍了，
现在差不多有一个月吧，
我前上个礼拜我就拿着他手机看，
但是平常也有打牌，
偶尔打个牌，
他是在那个工地做技术员的嘛，
然后每天上班点小时班，
下了班就跟这些工地上的那些什么包工头啊，
监理啊什么之类的都混在一块打牌，
我只听他说过两三百啊，
怎么怎样的，
我想着偶尔打一下成年人这样的人好多的，
我就没有在意，
结果上个礼拜我翻他手机，
我就发现他有一个礼拜每天都输1000多，
还是输给同一个人，
而且打了一个多礼拜，
我的天，
我那个月我看着他是有2万多的支出，
然后我想着是因为他们老出差，
会有一些垫资嘛，
我都没想到那么多，
现在我就感觉他妈妈也是在家里一直都打牌嘛，
但是老年人打的小，
我就没有在意，
他之前跟我订婚之前就是也有一次去我那个工作的城市出差，
也碰到过一次，
他说周末跟他几个同事一块去那个城市做房地产调研嘛，
然后他们几个打，
他说当时我赢了就有输的嘛，
当时我想着他说他是偶尔玩一回，
我也就没有干过，
当时隐隐约约感觉她脆我，
但是我想着没那么严重了，
所以这一次我也不知道是因为怀孕了，
心里太脆弱还是怎么了，
我就对未来挺迷茫，
我感觉我害怕，
我现在感觉这人很不靠谱。
我有点想把孩子拿了，
然后离婚，
又害怕我这个行为会不会是冲动的结果，
所以我想给你说一下，
然后听一下你那边的意见，
我跟你讲啊，
姐妹啊，
一般到了我这里说是怀孕了，
我一般很少很少说劝人家这个孩子不要了，
但你的情况不一样，
你的情况是我明明知道是火坑，
我不能眼见着你跳，
因为这个事情啊，
一个月充1万块钱打游戏这个事情啊，
他就是一个人的底色，
他就是火坑，
他说那话让我听来的话，
我甚至觉得有点可笑，
什么，
因为你跟你前面那个老公生的孩子，
你俩关系没有断，
所以我就要乱花钱，
你就按说出来的话，
你不觉得他自己有毛病吗？
我感觉他就是甩锅，
嗯，
我爸应我这个事儿跟我的朋友还有亲戚说了一下，
他们也说结了婚后有孩子，
他说他会这样甩锅这个心理，
有这个心理也是正常，
你你知道还有一件让我崩溃的是啥吗？
就像我们两个现在在一起啊，
他在这边出差都半年了，
就只有一件春秋的外套，
我来到这边之后，
我就说咱天冷了该买外套了啊，
我说再买一件，
我情愿花一点钱给他买，
他就不，
他买打算买的，
他都说人家买的不好，
结果他就打牌一点不犹豫，
这种观念就让我很崩溃，
我感觉这人价值观咋这个样子，
姐妹啊，
你挂了我的电话之后，
你去看一个电视剧的。
说这个电视剧的名字叫做春草，
你一定要看，
你可能用两个小时就能刷完这部电视剧的来龙去脉，
你刷一下那些博主对这个电视剧的男主角的人物性格的分析，
你要不要你的孩子将来有这样一个爸爸好不好，
然后你再决定，
不用担心，
虽然孩子是大家共同期待的，
就是担心以后他这个不改不了的话，
以我的性格，
我是肯定跟他过不下去的，
但过不下去，
到时候真的孩子生下来，
我就觉得你这孩子对我都不负责任，
你给我挂了，
你就去刷，
就说春草，
春天的春，
小草的草，
春草电视剧的解说有很多女性博主专门去解说，
专门去分析春草这里头她老公的人物的性格，
就是你老公那样啊，
好的，
我等一会儿去看一下啊，
就是她现在欠了还有网贷，
我结婚的时候他给我说，
因为他也没有父亲了嘛，
然后又结婚又那个的又有彩礼啊干嘛的，
之前他说他结婚的时候欠了3万多，
当时我就给他说，
我想到他工资一个月也有一个大个月，
我想到一年内还账足够了嘛，
结果他还账他还了一年，
他是不是五多也没还完，
现在的话，
我看他手里又有六七千的那种网贷，
抓紧决定啊姐妹。
第一，
咱已经生过一个孩子了，
咱不是说没孩子是吧？
第二，
现在才两个月，
杀伐决断才两个月，
第三，
你去看那个电视剧的解说，
你愿不愿意，
你将来的孩子的父亲是那样，
第4，
你想想怎么对得起孩子啊，
好吧的，
嗯，
就这样啊，
好，
拜拜你看啊，
龙飞在这里的话，
我是有原则的，
像昨天来了一个妹妹，
她是怀孕4个月的时候是吧，
他的那个对象就是没有不良嗜好，
没有没有，
没有其他的欠债啊什么的，
可能就是有一点小九九有点自私，
有点算计，
那情况是不一样的，
大家能懂龙菲姐的这个评判的标准吗？
人都有自私，
都有小九九，
都有算计，
是个人都会有，
那你说你怀疑四个月了，
像这种情况下，
能过就继续往下过，
就是接纳，
人都有自私，
人都有，
小九九就往下过，
但他这个情况不一样，
这个情况是才两个月，
加上男的打游戏，
一个月充1万块钱，
关键是他不觉得自己有错，
关键他觉得他自己花钱，
还得给自己花钱找个借口，
我为什么这么大手大脚的花钱呀？
还不是因为你有问题，
因为你和你前面生的那个孩子牵连不齐，
所以我乱花钱，
这种人的话，
他不管做什么事，
不管是遇到什么事儿，
他都是别人的错。
明白这个逻辑吗？
记得点赞关注哦。